come with me today on a journey through
the bowels of the conspiracy internet
and so-called race realism and race
ecology there's a guy that for your own
sake I hope you've never heard of I'm
gonna sort of ruin that now by telling
you that there's a guy named stefan
molyneux he is a canadian youtuber who
has been sort of dancing around white
nationalism and white supremacy for a
while I'm not gonna go through his full
slate of views but he's a men's rights
guy he's a race and IQ type he has
extremely unsound views on the existence
of mental illness and climate change so
just to give you like a very general
picture of him and normally he dances
around the white nationalism white
supremacy peace he was on cultural
critic Dave Rubens show not too long ago
and said that it's horrifying to him
that black people have low IQs and
whites and Asians have high IQs he
wishes that it were different but that
as an empiricist it's just the reality
sort of that type of thing right in the
last month though the white nationalist
white supremacist stuff has actually
become a lot more brazen it's still
slightly couched as he's just an
empiricist and it's the science but it's
much less disguised than usual so here's
one example about how he's spoken
against white nationalism but he's an
empiricist and he went to Poland and the
all-white population of Poland really
seemed to be doing very well take a look
at this video you know I go to Poland
what is it 99% white I don't need any
security the streets are incredibly
clean crime is almost non-existent
nobody gets called a racist there's no
talk of white privilege no identity
politics no endless diversity nagging
you know I spoken against white
nationalism but I'm an empiricist
I'm an empiricist I went to the country
I saw how it was like so there's that
and then he tweeted the day before
yesterday also about this issue a very
strange diatribe III would call it a
screed where he said my ancestors were I
guess it means white people were driven
out of Africa and struggled to survive
winter and hunger over thousands of
years they became smarter and wiser
through suffering they made the modern
world and now the Africans say we are
privileged and thieves no suffering made
us no more guilt and as you can see on
the screen I responded to this and said
can we now say you are a white
supremacist isn't it time to stop
dancing around this and as you can see
when you look at my tweet I tweeted this
yesterday and sort of forgot about it
then looked at my Twitter feed last
night and saw that my response had more
than 2,000 likes and a ton of sub
responses including from Stefan Molyneux
himself who spent a bunch of time last
night
slamming me on Twitter he responded to
this comment and said wow you're
ignorant of basic facts these same
environmental pressures caused East
Asians to have a higher average IQ than
whites it is now official I like how he
determines when I have officially done
something it is now official you post
confidently without a shred of knowledge
dunning-kruger in the flesh and he went
on and on
retweeting stuff targeted at me and his
followers started attacking me
many with anti-semitic comments
obviously do I even have to mention that
his followers started attacking me with
anti-semitic comments I think that
that's probably a superfluous
explanation I find all of this hilarious
and in some sense if Stefan Molyneux is
slamming me I consider it a compliment I
considered a badge of honor and I know
people are going to email me and say
David that's a fallacy and I know in
strict formal logic the argument if
someone is criticizing me I must be
doing something right that is logically
fallacious
I understand that my actions should be
evaluated on their own not based on who
is happy or upset about what I say and
what I do but in rhetoric where the
strict rules of formal logic don't apply
in the real world as I call it I'm sort
of invigorated by Stefan slamming me and
I tweeted that yesterday as well I said
in formal argument rules this is a
fallacy but in the rhetorical sense if
stefan molyneux was slamming me on the
internet I must be doing something right
and he seemed triggered by that he
responded to me at least once about that
if not more times pointing out I think
he has this catchphrase where he says
it's that's not an argument type of
thing which is something I also used I
don't know why it's his catchphrase but
it was quite an evening on on Twitter so
maybe the one mistake I made is instead
of saying can't we now just say you're
white supremacists maybe I should have
said white nationalists because these
folks already have a prepackaged
response when they get called white
supremacists which is they say listen
whites do have higher IQs except for
East Asians who have even higher IQs so
really we are East Asian supremacists
and that's not what you understand where
they go with that so if I made a mistake
maybe I should have used the term white
nationalists and we'll actually talk
about that on tomorrow's show whether we
should describe this milieu as white
supremacists or white nationalists or
what other terms maybe should apply if
you don't know stefan molyneux I kind of
am jealous of you I admire you you are
way better off for the people that do
know him hopefully you found his
triggering on Twitter last night as
entertaining as I found it and I'll let
you know if there is any follow-up here